[Applause]
can I get a show of hands who here has
ever googled themselves I have but what
started off as momentary curiosity very
quickly turned into an almost five year
rule that almost ruined my life I Google
Image reverse search myself a function
of Google that allows you to upload an
image and it shows you where it is on
the Internet this is me at 17 years old
an innocent selfie I took before a party
now before I continue I must point out
that what I'm about to talk about is
very confronting and graphic but there's
no way out this is a very confronting
issue in a split second
my screen was flooded with that image
and dozens more images of me that had
been stolen from my social media on
links connected to porn sites on these
sites nameless faceless sexual predators
had published highly explicit sexual
commentary about me and what they like
to do to me
cover her face read [ __ ] her body one
person wrote they also published
identifying information about me where I
lived what I studied who I was but
things got worse I soon discovered that
these sexual predators had doctored or
photoshopped my face
to the bodies of naked adult actresses
engaged in sexual intercourse on solo
shots of me being ejaculated on by two
men sperm was edited onto my face I was
edited onto the cover of a porn dvd
perpetrators had edited my images to
give the effects that my blouse was
transparent or see-through so you could
see my nipples perpetrators ejaculated
on images of me took photos of their
sperm and penises on these images and
posted them on to porn sites
come on printed pics is what they call
it now you might be wondering what sorts
of images I posted on social media this
is me at around 19 at the Claremont
hotel just a few suburbs away and they
superimposed that face into this and
things got worse nothing was off-limits
for these predators they even posted an
image with my little sister on these
sites - now you might be thinking well
you do dress provocatively even a little
sexually suggestive attention-seeking
maybe but just because a woman's body
gets attention doesn't mean she's
attention-seeking and what is
provocative anyway what is sexually
suggestive in some parts of the world
showing your ankles is promiscuous is
provocative it's just like no matter
what a woman wears it's always perceived
as more sexual than it is for me I just
wanted to feel pretty and confidence
what's so wrong with that now you might
be thinking well
can't you just set your social media on
private well these perpetrators were
calculated they befriended my friends on
social media under fake profiles they
followed the public galleries of the
events and places are regularly visited
but why why should one have to retreat
and hide out of fear that something like
this could happen what I post and what I
wear isn't an invitation to violate and
abuse me the only person that should be
changing their behavior is the
perpetrators
now you might be thinking why me well
I'm just one of the thousands upon
thousands of ordinary women who are
being preyed upon in these mass-scale
horrific online cultures websites and
threads that are dedicated to sexually
exploiting and doctoring ordinary images
of women into porn as I speak there are
women who are being preyed upon and they
don't even know it in the beginning I
tried seeking help I went to police
I contacted government agencies I even
tried to hire a private investigator but
they were too expensive there was
nothing that they could do I mean what
could you do when the sites are hosted
overseas and the perpetrators are from
overseas I was told I had to contact the
sites one by one notifying the
webmasters to get everything deleted and
so as you can imagine in complete and
utter fear and pain I did I contacted
the webmasters requesting that they
delete the material shared without
consent and I had some successes but I
also had some major setbacks the more I
fought the more sites I would discover
and with time the more my images were
being seen and shared in the tens of
thousands
I had one webmaster respond to me saying
he'll Oni doesn't delete the site if I
sent him nude photos of myself within 24
hours and this went on for years
fighting against his dodgy disgusting
sites
but I was fighting a losing battle and I
couldn't continue this any longer for my
own mental health but what could I do
maybe I thought if I spoke out I could
reclaim my name and I could rewrite my
narrative on my own terms
maybe if I spoke out I could raise
awareness about this maybe I could even
try to change the law and so I did
I spoke out publicly late last year and
news of my story reverberating around
the world but this was the response
she's a fat ugly [ __ ] she's a [ __ ]
she's an attention-seeking piece of
trash feel flattered baby it's a
compliment
I was victim blamed and [ __ ] shamed and
told I was deserving of what happened to
me and quite frankly that was more
difficult for me to endure than my
actual experiences of image based abuse
but I couldn't let this criticism defeat
me I knew what the perpetrators had done
was wrong and I knew what they were
doing to others was wrong and so I
petitioned I sent her impassioned pleas
for support but it didn't work I think I
got like 330 signatures and that was
really disheartening but I then
contacted my state and federal MPs and I
was referred to the New South Wales
Attorney General's Department who were
already in the process of drafting new
laws to criminalize the non-consensual
distribution of intimate images image
based sexual abuse some of you may know
it as a revenge porn and soon I became a
spokesperson a public face for the new
laws but I must point out I do not in
any way shape or form want to take
credit for this change in the law this
is on the backs of cyber safety experts
of researchers of the Attorney General's
Department of so many people who have
fought for years New South Wales was the
first state in all the world to
specifically include a provision on
altering images something that happened
to me something you certainly didn't
don't hear about very often and now a CT
has also criminalized this
also with a provision on altered images
and next year WI is introducing
legislation and hopefully they introduce
a provision on alternate images and I
urge every state in every country in
this world to follow suit because right
now there's no justice for people like
me despite it all
despite the hate and despite the
criticism despite the fact that I'm
never going to get justice because my
experience has happened before this
movement of law reform speaking out was
the best thing I've ever done because I
know for a fact that is helped people
and I just want to live in a world where
regardless of what I wear or what I post
that I'm still worthy of being treated
with dignity and respect respect now
that's an idea we're sharing
[Applause]
[Music]